but the EU has actually entertained
sanctioning Tucker Carlson over his
interview with Vladimir Putin several
members of EU Parliament Parliament have
expressed their intention to have him
reviewed as it were it it seems like a
long shot but it is very interesting and
it brings up a very interesting point
which I'm going to just say it
bluntly why does anyone care that Tucker
Carlson interviewed the president of a
country we are not at war with because
the answer is obvious we are at war with
Russia and they are now outraged that an
American journalist Tucker Carlson is
interviewing the president of a country
we are at war with and that's it I think
it's plainly obvious and it's been for a
long time most of us who've been paying
attention is that we are in this war
Chuck Schumer recently said we could
lose this war and that's why they're mad
they have unilaterally engaged in a war
without Congressional approval without
declaration and they're trying to hide
it from the American people